[Musique]
le projet c'est de faire un tour de
France des remplacements pour trouver
une région qui nous plaît assez pour
s'installer définitivement
je sais que partout je dirais il y aura
des opportunités je pourrais m'installer
même si il y a déjà un médecin en place
il cherchera souvent un collaborateur ou
un successeur
je peux aller n'importe où en France il
y aura toujours besoin d'un médecin
parti du Gard Héloïse benoît jeune
généraliste entame un périple d'un an
elle envisage de travailler en Alsace en
Auvergne en Corrèze en Vendée en
Bretagne comme généraliste jusqu'à
trouver le lieu où s'installer elle
n'aura que l'embarras du choix tant la
pénurie de médecins écriante durant un
an nous l'avons suivi au cœur d'une
France ou un tiers des habitants vit
dans un désert médical
[Musique]
direction l'Alsace et la médecine de
campagne pour Héloïse
à 25 km de Colmar Orbey dans le
Haut-Rhin
[Musique]
et ses 3500 habitants jusqu'à il y a un
an il y avait deux médecins mais à 67
ans le vétéran des généralistes a pris
sa retraite et donc là vous allez avoir
ajouter une vaccination à droite
seul reste la Docteur Dominique
Spielmann autant dire qu'elle est ravie
de se faire remplacer quelques jours par
Héloïse donc après on fait changer de
patience donc pareil il suffit de taper
ici les coordonnées c'est pas la peine
de retourner sur Amélie là on est dans
vaccination la gêne médecin doit
s'adapter très vite parfois quand on
arrive à petit mot qui explique les
dernières urgences ou les choses à
suivre et on prend le train en route
quoi c'est des fois il faut tout faire
depuis le départ à la retraite de son
associé la docteur Spielmann travaille
plus de 65 heures par semaine un récent
rapport révèle d'ailleurs que près d'un
généraliste sur deux serait en burn out
là je fais des heures pas possible j'ai
augmenté mon activité quand même de
façon conséquente clairement il faut que
je trouve quelqu'un rapidement parce que
sans physiquement et moralement voilà
c'est un peu difficile vous espérez
secrètement qu'elle reste en fait
[Rires]
l'après-midi
je vous en prie première consultation
cette mère et sa fille qui ont toutes
les deux très mal au ventre
comme ça
tu les poses
[Musique]
la mère de la petite Lola a dû batailler
pour pouvoir consulter 5 jours d'attente
minimum aujourd'hui j'ai appelé pour
prendre rendez-vous on m'a dit pas avant
mercredi et en forçant j'ai pu avoir un
rendez-vous et c'est tout le temps comme
ça les autres médecins ne veulent pas
prendre de nouveaux passions parce
qu'ils sont aussi débordés enfin c'est
depuis le covid c'est la catastrophe
et les passions vont s'enchaîner toute
la journée
surtout le secteur il manque de
généraliste tout comme de spécialistes
Didier Lucas aime sa vie ici mais il
envisage de partir
et donc on va déménager d'Orléans
parce qu'on sait que là-bas il y a une
maison médicale là-bas il y a des kinés
là-bas il y a des infirmières et moi je
veux pas arriver à la retraite et ramer
pour aller trouver un spécialiste quoi
[Musique]
un accident du travail
il est enflé le soir quoi
des rhumes des cas de covid
les pathologies se succèdent et ne se
ressemblent pas
jusqu'à la consultation de 19 heures
le 26e passion de la journée
en consultant son dossier Héloïse
découvre que ce monsieur a eu une
embolie pulmonaire il y a deux ans
ce soir-là
ils se sont oppressés
mais il est avare en détail sur son état
de santé
jusqu'à demain vous faites demain matin
la prise de sang OK
Héloïse redoute une nouvelle embolie
elle va lui prescrire toute une batterie
d'examens
[Musique]
à faire au plus vite
allez au revoir c'est typique du dernier
cas du soir typique du dernier cas de
quand on est fatigué que qu'il y a les
cas les plus compliquées c'est plus
rigolo
[Musique]
là comme ça c'est difficile à 19h en
plus ici il y a pas de d'infirmières
pour faire des injections il y a pas de
on peut pas c'est pas comme à l'hôpital
on peut faire le scanner tout de suite
donc
il est 19h30 après 12 heures de travail
Héloïse benoît va rejoindre sa famille
car dans son tour de France des
remplacements il y a un conjoint et deux
enfants qui l'accompagnent
le temps de son séjour à Orbey et Louise
a loué un gîte de montagne où elle vit
avec sa famille
[Musique]
en général il y a de la brune
et toute la vallée est recouverte de
brume c'est pour ça qu'ils appellent ça
la mère de brume Olivier était monteur
vidéo puis directeur de théâtre quand
Éloïse finissait ses études mais le
confinement a servi d'éléments
déclencheur il a tout quitté pour la
suivre mon quotidien c'est vraiment ça
c'est vraiment tourné vers les enfants
quoi tout ce qui est école et puis faire
à manger quoi
après si tu commences
en Tour de France qui est au moins qui
reste à la maison parce que c'est pas
possible
tous les deux mois
le travail d'Éloïse ne se limite pas au
cabinet ce jour-là elle reçoit un
résultat d'analyse du patient de la
veille celui de l'embolie pulmonaire ton
redouté oui je vous rappelle au sujet de
votre prise de sang
donc les dix mères sont très positifs
donc ça ça indique que vous faites
sûrement un caillot quelque part
et vivre aux antécédents ce serait mieux
d'aller aux urgences à Colmar pour faire
l'enjeu scanner
le patient va devoir aller immédiatement
à 25 km de la
deux fois par semaine et Louise fait des
visites à domicile aux alentours d'Orbey
la plupart du temps pour des personnes
âgées qui ne peuvent pas se déplacer
pour eux la présence d'un médecin de
famille est capitale bonjour
[Musique]
chez le docteur Benoît c'est moi qui
remplace le docteur Spielmann
pour ce couple Héloïse est une véritable
bouée de sauvetage
ça va vous mangez
vous avez bon appétit mais
il me dit
Marie souffre de la maladie d'Alzheimer
et son mari a un peu du mal à tout
assumer car de tous les côtés on est
débordés il y a l'équipe spéciale
d'Alzheimer qui devait venir vous voir
depuis avril c'est ça
ménage
que j'avais pas vu personne
je suis obligé de le faire
finalement ça commence à faire beaucoup
hein
ça suffit j'ai eu un concert alors déjà
c'est déjà pas mal
sur les 228 000 médecins français - 200
000 sont généralistes
les étudiants préfèrent s'orienter vers
des spécialités la médecine générale est
boudée
de médecins parce que c'est en train de
changer mais auparavant même pendant mes
études on a que 6 mois d'expérience sur
le terrain et donc quand on connaît pas
un exercice forcément ça nous fait peur
et on n'a pas envie d'y aller donc du
coup toutes les spécialités c'est plus
demander que la médecine générale
à Orbey la population vieillit et les
besoins de médecins sont grandissants
alors on tente d'attirer les jeunes avec
un projet financé par la commune l'État
et la région
[Musique]
Dominique Spielmann tient à montrer à
Héloïse la future maison médicale pour
lui donner envie de rester
maison de santé pluridisciplinaire donc
mon cabinet moi ça sera le deuxième et
de les trois quatre vitres après c'est
le cabinet du troisième médecin au
dessus ça sera kiné il a un plateau de
100 mètres carrés et donc on a aussi un
cabinet qui est prévu pour accueillir un
ou deux dentistes parce qu'il y a plus
de dentistes sur le secteur enfin sur la
commune déjà depuis deux ans et le
dentiste de la commune d'à côté va
prendre sa retraite là dans les
prochains temps certains cabinets
pourraient rester vides le nombre de
généralistes a chuté de plus de 11%
depuis 2010 du fait des départs à la
retraite des départs pourtant
prévisibles
parce que à l'époque quand j'ai fini ma
médecine fin des années 90 on savait
déjà à l'époque que au vu d'une mirrus
clausus il y aurait un déficit de
remplacement des médecins qui partaient
à la retraite à partir de 2010 donc il
suffit de consulter la pyramide des âges
des médecins qui partaient en retraite
c'était tout à fait envisageable donc
quelle était la volonté des pouvoirs
publics de
restreindre ce nombre de médecins qui
pouvait sortir partir de la fac à
Marseille c'était il y a longtemps
maintenant presque 10 ans il y avait
déjà en centre-ville les médecins qui
partaient à la retraite qui n'étaient
pas remplacés et donc il y avait trois
quatre médecins pour un quartier donc
désert médical ça veut pas dire c'est
pas du tout
récemment le numéro slausus a été un peu
desserré pas suffisant pour compenser
les futurs départs à la retraite
le charme de l'Alsace n'a pas opéré
quelques semaines après notre tournage
Héloïse décide de continuer son tour de
France
[Musique]
l'étape suivante la Tour d'Auvergne un
petit village de 600 habitants dans le
Puy-de-Dôme fort pressé de retrouver un
médecin nous sommes au mois de février
et toute la famille découvre la région
[Musique]
1500 à 1525
Héloïse était très attendu dès son
arrivée un appartement gratuit lui a été
prêté c'est le vert qui nous a ouvert la
porte il nous avait acheté du fromage du
pain pour que le premier soir en soit
pas et ils avaient ils ont réaménagé un
peu l'intérieur ils ont vraiment fait
tout pour qu'on sente comme chez nous et
c'est vrai qu'on se sent comme un peu
comme chez nous
pour qu'ils puissent pour qu'il puisse
travailler
c'est un appartement communal donc on a
encore on a aucun frais ça fait partie
des avantages que l'on peut que l'on
peut
sur le versant ouest du massif du Sancy
que se niche la Tour d'Auvergne son
maire cherche activement un médecin
depuis près de deux ans
[Musique]
on fait la queue le long on se double
pas allez
infirmier de profession Yannick
Tournadre et multi casquette en plus de
gérer la commune il vient de passer son
brevet de moniteur de ski pour que la
petite station près de son village
puisse continuer de donner des cours aux
enfants
viens derrière moi derrière moi derrière
moi il s'active pour qu'Eloïse est envie
de s'installer dans son village à la fin
de ses deux mois d'essai
comment faire pour trouver un médecin
dans un pays qui en manque tellement
dans ce contexte là où il y a pénurie
dans tous ces territoires et ben on
n'avait pas les moyens de dérouler un
tapis rouge
du coup il fallait qu'on use de nos
charmes et nos charmes c'est aujourd'hui
c'est des journées comme aujourd'hui
c'est c'est une qualité de vie c'est un
environnement privilégié pour éduquer
ses enfants etc donc voilà on a essayé
de mettre ça le plus en avant possible
car la Tour d'Auvergne est en deuil
traumatisé d'avoir perdu son médecin
brutalement mort du covid en début
d'épidémie depuis c'est le docteur du
hameau d'à côté qui essaye d'absorber
les patients en vain alors comme le
maire Laetitia la boulangère est au
petit soin avec Héloïse
vous allez bien oui
je vais vous prendre un gros pince s'il
vous plaît
c'est surtout monsieur il était trop
déçu
et moi
docteur du coup si les gens vont chez le
docteur il s'arrêteront à la boulangerie
voilà si après ils vont à la boulangerie
ils vont à la pharmacie enfin on est
tous on est tous ensemble
merci beaucoup et bonne journée au
revoir
pour un bourg de 600 habitants la Tour
d'Auvergne n'est pas si mal dotée
il y a toujours quelques commerces
essentiels
une pharmacie
un bureau de poste une école primaire et
même un collège de quoi donner envie à
Héloïse de s'y installer car sans cela
ce serait l'internat pour ses enfants
dès l'âge de 11 ans mais le maire veut
que sa commune soit encore plus
attractive
il veut proposer au même endroit un
cabinet de consultation et un logement à
tout à l'heure
on a un projet d'offrir un médecin
l'outil de travail qui puisse permettre
soit Éloïse soit un docteur devenir
s'installer juste avec ses valises du
coup c'est cette maison qui est juste à
côté de la mairie qui est un peu dans
son jus aujourd'hui un peu abandonné ça
permet d'être actif pour des médecins ça
participe à la vie du bourg avec la
pharmacie à 50 mètres le cabinet de kiné
à une centaine de mètres le cabinet
infirmier aussi donc cette maison qui
est fermée depuis deux trois ans elle va
retrouver une vie un usage
Yannick Tournadre vient juste de boucler
le financement des travaux heureusement
d'autres collectivités que la commune
vont mettre la main au portefeuille ils
sont presque d'annoncer la bonne
nouvelle à Héloïse
je pense que la région est prête à nous
suivre les dernières infos sont bonnes
donc du coup ce serait tu penses pour
quand
on passe la commande à l'architecte des
produits permis de construire
tout ça tout ça préparez vos marchés et
début des travaux fin d'année
d'ailleurs le courant passe bien entre
le maire infirmier et la jeune médecin
tous deux partage le constat d'un
système de soins à bout de souffle on
est arrivé là parce que voilà on a
regardé trop le chiffre et du coup on a
voulu rentabiliser notre système de
santé et c'est parental d'un système de
santé c'est comme l'éducation nationale
c'est pas rentable
comme tous les déserts médicaux la Tour
d'Auvergne a été déclarée zone
d'intervention prioritaire
autrement dit si Héloïse reste l'État
lui versera 20.000 euros d'aide à
l'installation
mais en y regardant de plus près elle
découvre encore d'autres avantages
donc c'est pas négligeable et pendant 5
ans ça c'est dans toutes les zones
rurales même pour les autres professions
libérales ou les artisans les cinq
premiers années on est exonéré d'impôt
sur le revenu donc c'est assez actif en
fait ah oui tout à fait ça fait que j'ai
pas besoin de faire d'emprunt pour
commencer déjà donc ça ça change quand
même les choses en contrepartie Héloïse
s'engage à rester cinq ans au minimum
sur place sous peine de devoirs
rembourser les aides
après un mois seulement d'exercice la
jeune médecin commence à apprécier ses
habitants de La Tour d'Auvergne qui ont
appris à se contenter de ce qu'ils ont
ici on ne va pas chez le médecin à tort
et à travers
Sylvie Charbonnel est productrice de
Saint-Nectaire il y a deux jours une
chaudière de 300 kg lui est tout
simplement tombé dessus
je vais vous examiner et les vertiges
c'était pas des vertiges quand vous
baissiez la tête c'était pas toute la
pièce qui tournait autour de nous
on va regarder un peu la jambe
et dès que vous la pliez ça vous fait
suivre ça vous fait mal de toute façon
la chaudière et vous est tombée ici
dessus en entier comme ça d'accord là ça
vous fait moins mal que si vous le
faisiez tout seul
un contact direct avec les patients qui
plait à Héloïse
[Musique]
mais va-t-elle rester ou continuer son
périple des déserts médicaux pour se
laisser tenter par une autre région de
France
[Musique]
nous la retrouvons six mois plus tard
nous sommes début septembre il est 8h15
du matin
s'il te plaît
alors je dois rester à la Tour
d'Auvergne oui oui les enfants sont
rentrés à l'école fini les cours à la
maison Maxence et Aurore sont désormais
scolarisés au village ils y étaient les
effectifs de la petite école trois
niveaux et 20 élèves seulement par
classe
cette ambiance familiale autant que la
présence du collège pour plus tard ont
été décisives on a décidé très vite
finalement on pensait que ça allait
prendre plus de temps pour savoir si on
allait s'habituer mais dès les premières
semaines on sentait très bien très bien
accueillis il y avait tout ce qu'il
fallait pour les enfants pour nous donc
ça a été facile comme décision
[Musique]
Yannick Tournadre le maire lui est
soulagé
en tant qu'élu mais aussi en tant
qu'infirmier bonjour Marie
ça va avec Éloïse Benoît ils font une
équipe en somme pour prendre soin des
plus isolés j'ai eu le docteur Benoît
donc qui m'a dit pour ces petits boutons
on va faire une prise de sang et il n'a
que de bons échos des patients sur cette
médecin venus de la ville comme on dit
ici voilà
il est très très bien donc elle est pas
fière alors ça veut dire quoi
elle va bien pour la campagne quoi elle
a pas des grands toilettes
et ça ça compte ici
vous êtes mieux à l'aise enfin moi
personnellement
le chien le maire infirmier veut croire
à la revanche des villages
il veut insuffler de l'espoir dans ces
terres isolées
alors qu'est-ce qui dit Monsieur Bernard
tout va bien depuis hier
Yannick espère que la période post covid
va donner aux citadins des envies de
campagne
c'est à eux mais ici tout le monde n'est
pas convaincu
complètement c'est ça continue de moins
en moins il y aura plus besoin de
docteur ni rien parce qu'il y a pas
grand chose je pense qu'on a touché le
forum sur Bernard on va on va remonter
la pente maintenant
il y a des endroits où on va descendre à
plus en tout cas oui à la Tour
d'Auvergne médecin et infirmiers sont
plus que des soignants mauvais temps
arrive
c'est une surveillance générale de
l'état de santé de Monsieur Bernard et
puis de son environnement aussi voilà il
a perdu son épouse il y a à peu près
deux mois et effectivement on savait pas
si il pourrait rester à la maison ou si
il serait obligé d'aller en institution
donc
pour lui ça se passe bien là voilà il a
passé ce virage et il va pouvoir finir
sa vie chez lui là où il est né c'est
formidable c'est formidable voilà
[Musique]
Héloïse elle a pris ses marques
certains de ses passions la tutoient
même
que
j'ai ton adresse
dans le village elle a fait faire des
analyses à des patients qui parfois n'en
avaient pas eu depuis longtemps on va
enlever la marelle
et qui est pas si rosé qui est progressé
mais le problème ben il y a un cancer
et c'est Héloïse qui me l'a trouvé c'est
vrai que je pensais pas en étant depuis
si peu longtemps installé découvrir et
annoncer autant de choses comme ça oui
vous avez annoncé combien de cancers
Yannick le sait Héloïse est resté dans
son village car elle y a trouvé des
services publics lui se bat tous les
jours pour les conserver il en est
certain c'est le seul moyen d'attirer
des soignants à la Tour d'Auvergne on a
des services mais aujourd'hui l'État a
encore envie de serrer un petit peu les
boulons et nos services deviennent un
peu fragiles parce que ça coûte tout ça
s'il n'y a que des agriculteurs dans nos
campagnes et si on n'a pas l'offre de
services qui va bien à côté le médecin
viendra pas se paumer à la campagne
c'est sûr
ce soir il va plus loin réunion de
travail pour créer une CPTs comprenez
une communauté de professionnels de
territoire de santé ça va en clair le
travail en commun sur 40 villages de
tous les soignants et les élus pour
améliorer l'offre de soins et lutter
contre les déserts médicaux
un maillage territorial vivement
encouragé par l'État
et Samuel jeune mère comme moi on va
dire comme ça
mais quand on évoque les déserts
médicaux surgit très vite la question de
la liberté d'installation pour les
médecins
sur le vélo la problématique c'est ces
gens là qui ont fait que l'on forme et
tout il faudrait quand même durer parce
que il y a de l'argent public qui permet
je dirais cette formation et tout mais
je pense qu'il faudrait qu'on l'utiliser
aussi certaines contraintes en disant et
ben il faudra peut-être aller dans les
zones rurales au niveau de de vos
cabinets est-ce que c'est un sens de
vouloir contraindre des libéraux est-ce
que ça peut seulement aboutir
je pense qu'il viendraulent
c'est pas dans leur
corpus idéologique
sur cette question le débat reste ouvert
et transcende les clivage politique
loin de ses considérations Héloïse et
Olivier baptisent des projets le matin
15 l'après-midi
Olivier cherche du travail et il est
déjà quelqu'un dans le village il est le
mari de la médecin
anonymat c'est-à-dire moi je suis fils
de médecin aussi et au moins ça me fait
penser moi quand j'étais quand j'étais
petit c'est-à-dire que moi je me
promenais en fait dans le village
incroyant comme j'ai la vie avec moi
mais en fait tout le monde me
connaissait et là c'est exactement le
cas tout le monde me dit bonjour et moi
je connais pas tout le monde encore
quant à Héloïse la gamine de la ville
elle n'en revient toujours pas de son
choix de vie
[Musique]
j'ai su très tôt que je voulais faire
médecine déjà à 17 ans 16 ans jamais
j'aurais imaginé m'installer dans un
tout petit village de 600 habitants
aujourd'hui en France les habitants de
Provence-Alpes-Côte d'Azur sont les
mieux loti avec plus de 400 médecins
pour 100000 habitants quand les Normands
avec
290 médecins seulement sont les plus
délaissés
[Musique]